[Music]
neil joins us in new brunswick new
jersey neil welcome to the ramsay show
hey george how's it going great how can
i help
yeah so right now i'm 22 years old i'm
making um around 90 take home and i've
been listening to you guys for
i think three or four years now since i
was like 18.
awesome so a big fan
and kind of have a small problem going
on in my life
so i do listen with my parents right now
and
i don't pay rent um technically but i do
end up paying you know one to two k you
know putting
money into the house
like groceries and miscellaneous
expenses
and just wanted to ask you
i don't
you know like staying at home
and
i want to
finance you know a big wedding coming up
uh hopefully when i'm like 25 26
um do you think i should kind of
move out or kind of save money and
continue staying at home
i think you should move out based on the
information you just gave me and let me
just be clear you said finance a wedding
that worried me do you mean pay cash
no no i just wanted to kind of save up
for for a wedding like a bigger wedding
he's got so you're not going into debt
for this wedding
no no okay you worried me never use the
word finance it scares me
you spooked me there because you've been
following us for a few years now so have
you followed the baby steps do you have
any
debt no so um luckily my parents did pay
for my college tuition so no debt just
that's why i'm trying to make the
correct move so i can
save up for this wedding do you have an
emergency fund
yes i do how much is in there how many
months of expenses
um it's six months uh so but you don't
have many expenses
right so how much do you have in there
30 000 i've kind of put in like a big
chunk of my first year salary into that
very cool and you're investing 15 of
your income into retirement
yep and uh maxed out my
401k that my employer sponsors so i
think i get like a seven percent match
wow so are you investing more than
fifteen percent
um i haven't looked into
that like it's not too specific um i'm
just trying to put in as much into you
know
investing i don't know the exact um
percentages okay well i would i would
keep it at 15 right now only because
you're 22 and you've got a lot of other
financial goals to hit including paying
for this wedding are you dating someone
right now or is this just future
thinking
um dating someone for like six years now
oh wow
so this this is like a high school
relationship
that has gone well
you have no debt in an emergency fund i
mean half the women listening right now
are like man i wish i could find a neil
out there
yeah but um
this wedding that i'm kind of thinking
of um kind of
in like the 500k kind of range but i'm
sorry i hold the phones
you said 500 000 for a wedding
george have you ever been to indian
wedding i've seen it on tv
i've seen love is blind if that
oh my goodness man they're very
expensive
is that just normal
yeah hold on who's paying for this
sometimes
yeah so i don't want to get my parents
involved that's why i'm trying to kind
of do my due diligence to
make these steps proper and so i can pay
for this can you break the mold and do
like a 50 000 wedding which is still
like really expensive for most people
yeah i mean maybe i can um he'll be
shunned by all the people
yeah true i get it
man i mean that feels just exorbitant
for you to be paying
on your own i feel like it's like hey
mom and dad if this is your reputation
on the line then you can fund it right
but i've got goals and the wedding is
one day and i want to set myself up for
the rest of my life with my wife not
throw a party that makes the parents
look good
true
i mean right isn't that that's a piece
of the the cultural aspect
yeah um that is true but um usually
these like weddings like last like maybe
like a week long so it's not just one
day
um but yeah your logic definitely
doesn't make sense
man that just took my breath away i
think it took america's breath away too
i mean
you could buy a house for that much
money
yeah um
yeah the the reputation really matters
though
well um i can't stop you from doing that
but i would say let's make a plan to
where you're not having to pay for that
because that's overwhelming for a 22
year old
even though you're crushing it to go hey
it's on you to pay for a half million
dollar wedding
yeah uh they did pay for my college
that's why i'm not kind of resorting to
asking my parents um but yeah
that that does make sense
now have you talked to have you talked
to your girlfriend about her parents and
what they would pitch in
no so i'm kind of like an early bird on
this um since i'm you know this is a
plan three four years out i
kind of don't want to freak her out by
mentioning you know marriage and stuff
um so no i haven't hold on you've been
dating for six years and you think
you're gonna freak her out by mentioning
marriage
but we're still 22 at the end of the day
you know uh we just got out the college
lifestyle
working corporate jobs now so it's not
you know fully into the picture yet now
does she come from the same cultural
background as you
yes
okay so you're both on board to just
throw half a million at this wedding
pretty much yeah now culturally is it
usually a split amount that families pay
how does this normally go down
yeah so normally it is split among the
bride's parents and the groom's parents
so the
bride and groom don't usually um
like pay for the expenses for the
wedding and that's where my head is at i
mean if the parents want to do that
that's great but if you say hey they're
not going to foot the bill and it's on
me then sorry we're not doing a half
million dollar wedding
yeah that doesn't make sense yeah
because here's the problem if you're
gonna do a half million dollar wedding
and pay for it you're gonna have to live
with your parents until the day you get
married
and that's not a good plan
so i think you need to move out you need
to start your life on your own you need
to have some more serious conversations
with your girlfriend as you head towards
marriage
and we've got to figure out a game plan
for what this future looks like and i i
mean it just hurts my heart that there's
half a million dollar weddings out there
i mean they look amazing don't get me
wrong i would love to be invited to one
one day so throw me an invite neil if
you're gonna throw the party that's
great and you're footing the bill
but man you're crushing it i mean 22
years old with a 90 000 take home pay no
debt emergency fund you're investing
you're doing great and you can afford to
move out and get your own place if you
want to
uh and i wouldn't be sticking around
with mom and dad too much longer
gotcha
makes sense
all right well my work here is done uh
keep me posted on this wedding send me
photos and videos on instagram all right
neil
of course thank you george appreciate it
oh
i just had to deflate after that call i
literally can't breathe
trying to fathom spending five hundred
thousand dollars
so fun fact me and my wife
we won a free wedding that was a twenty
eight thousand
wedding package and i mean i thought we
won the lottery but it turns out that
was like a poor person's wedding
compared to these wild indian weddings
that are a week long that's incredible
and on top of that it still cost us
money to throw another reception because
the wedding had limits on how many
people could attend and all that so you
were down to like four guests can attend
and so we threw another reception
that we helped pay for with with you
know our families and it was great and
it was worth it but man let me tell you
i don't remember much from the wedding
except the photos
i don't i can't tell you i can count on
one finger how many times i've went back
and watched the wedding footage and
reminisced because the truth is the
focus is now on our marriage together
just us two
couldn't tell you who was there and all
the faces and invitations we sent out uh
kelly was there she's pointing at me now
reminding me that she was there
appreciate you kelly thanks for the gift
whatever it was
but man weddings the whole thing is a
scam and i get that we love to celebrate
and it's a big day for people but
remember it's about you two it's about
your marriage it's about your future
it's not about impressing people it's
not about keeping up a reputation